China has colonized Latin America and
the U.S hasn't even noticed for decades
America was the only superpower that had
his tentacles in Latin America but when
all that American interest got re-routed
to the Middle East after 9 11 it left
Latin America wide open for China to
swoop in to start spreading its
influence so the Chinese Communist party
did exactly that today Latin America
looks very Latin from the outside but
underneath the surface they are de facto
owned by the Chinese today Latin America
owes billions upon billions of dollars
to China Chinese investors and Chinese
businesses are involved in almost every
sector of their economy they're allowing
China to sneak in military equipment
train their soldiers and build a
strategic Port along their coasts and
China is using all this leverage they
have over Latin America to pressure
Latin America into accepting their
vision of how the world should work like
how conveniently Latin America now seems
to always vote in favor of China at the
U.N or how most of Latin America also
refuses to recognize Taiwan as a
sovereign states that's how the Chinese
move a 5 000 year old country moves slow
right they move slow and then by the
time you realize you're part of the
mudslide it's too late China has crept
up on America's doorstep while America
was too distracted to even notice and
now it may be too late to stop them the
People's Republic of China are long-term
strategic competitor continues its
Relentless march to expand economic
diplomatic technological informational
and Military influence in Latin America
and the Caribbean and challenges U.S
influence in all of these domains
without U.S leadership negative PRC
influence in this region could soon
resemble the self-serving predatory
influence that now holds in Africa
China is attacking America from all
sides while China takes over Latin
America China is also getting America's
addicted to things like Tick Tock and
other substances wink wink but one
company is on a mission to help you
break your bad habits and that company
is our sponsor fume fume is an
Innovative award-nominated device that
makes Breaking Bad Habits easy instead
of electronics fume is completely
natural instead of vapor fume uses
flavored air and instead of harmful
chemicals fume uses all natural
delicious flavors that way instead of
breaking your bad habit by going cold
turkey or by replacing it with a
different bad habit feel unless you just
remove the bad from your habit it's got
an adjustable airflow dial for the
perfect drag and it's designed with
movable parts and magnets that you can
fidget with this gives your fingers a
lot to do which is great for
de-stressing and anxiety stopping is
something we all put off because it's
hard but switching a theme is easy
enjoyable and even fun fuse got over a
hundred thousand customers and thousands
of success stories and there is no
reason why you can't be one of them and
it starts by picking up fumes Journey
pack right now and to get you started
FEMA's giving you guys 10 off just pause
the video and go to tryfume.com by
clicking the link below or scan the QR
code on the screen and use code J Trend
to get 10 off your journey pack now
that's tryfum.com Jake Tran for 10 off
your order today
make no mistake Latin America is
extremely important to both the US and
China Latin America is the US's largest
supplier of oil Latin America is an
agricultural Powerhouse they export
one-fourth of their total production by
contrast another agricultural superpower
Asia Only exports six percent of its
production from grains to fruits to
sugar to Coffee Latin America has all
Latin America is also filled with a ton
of Natural Resources like copper iron
tin lead zinc natural gas while also
being the largest source of illegal
drugs and immigration it's also home to
the Panama Canal which is obviously
extremely important for the us although
as individual countries their economies
aren't very big combined Latin America's
GDP sits at around five and a half
trillion dollars placing it in third
place right behind China and the U.S as
the third largest economy in the world
and of course controlling the region
puts China right at the doorstep of the
US there is a reason why the Spanish the
Portuguese and the US have always tried
to dominate the region there's just too
much to exploit but since Latin America
is no stranger to colonizers how on
Earth did they fall prey to another
colonizer China this time
[Music]
when U.S cabinet members visit Latin
America these days all they do is talk
about China
when Chinese cabinet members visit Latin
America all they do is talk about trade
and investment and well there's an
interesting contrast there and I suppose
you can guess which one is more
effective to understand how China has
been able to conquer Latin America you
have to understand that Latin America
welcomed China with open arms see before
China started trading with Latin America
the only superpower Latin America had to
go to for trade and support was a good
old us of a and the US did not provide
very good we'll call it customer service
to the Latin Americans coups
assassinations violent overthrows
exploitation election meddling and the
theft of Natural Resources this is how
the US has treated Latin America and
they are sick of it so when China
offered Latin America trade loans and
support without the threat of violence
and Mafia style tactics Latin America
happily agreed China is coming in and
offering better deals I think the
Chinese learned from the mistakes that
that Russia's economic Hitmen in the
United States is made I don't think
they're making those mistakes they're
gonna make their own set of mistakes but
they're not making those and so actually
president XI has has gone on record uh
as promising and and I've got in front
of me right now the the the the the four
points that he's he's recently made as a
promise to any country where they go in
and you're quite correct that they go in
and they bring in their own Workforce as
they bring in their own engineering
companies and they use resources as
collateral just as we did but he's also
promised that one we won't interfere in
other countries Internal Affairs two we
won't impose our will on other countries
in any way three we won't attach
political agendas to Assistance programs
and four we won't seek selfish political
gains through our investment and
financial policies so that's in direct
contrast to what the the World Bank and
the and the IMF have done let the
Chilean ambassador to China sudden quote
the US is competing with China for
influence in Latin America but the US
has little to offer end quotes and words
Latin America slowly started getting
embedded with the Chinese especially
with trade Latin American exports to
China are mainly soybeans copper
petroleum oil and other raw materials
that China needs to drive as industrial
developments and China is eating up all
these exports so now economies like
Brazil Chile and Peru have become
completely dependent on China these
countries need to keep training with
China to survive they need that Chinese
money for infrastructure social programs
and for the government to run which
means China now has unimaginable
influence over Latin America which means
no one wants to fight the henna feeds it
no one wants to push away a country
that's bringing them more than 450
billion dollars in trade a year as
Brazil's ambassador to China Sun could
we rather not be so dependent on exports
to China but what is the alternative
it's just more profitable to sell to
China than anywhere else End quotes
that's why when the CCP comes knocking
and ask these countries to cast U.N
votes in favor of China's agenda they
happily agreed when the CCP says Taiwan
is roughly part of China and any country
that does recognize Taiwan as a
sovereign state won't be doing business
with China all of Latin America nods in
compliance quote in the past four years
the Dominican Republic El Salvador and
Panama have each switched their
recognition from Taiwan to China end
quotes in fact take a look at this map
the red are countries that have formal
relations with China and the blue are
countries that have formal relations
with Taiwan only but trade is just one
of the tentacles that China has over
Latin America the next one is even more
pernicious
[Music]
once trade was established China went to
Latin America and made them an offer
signed this dotted line and we will make
you rich you'll get these massive
infrastructure projects like a proposed
transcontinental Railway that can link
South America's Atlantic and Pacific
Coast from Brazil to Chile or like
investing 73 billion dollars into Latin
America's raw material sector including
building refineries and processing
plants in countries with significant
amounts of coal copper natural gas oil
and uranium China tells Latin America
that these infrastructure projects are
going to Skyrocket their economies
that's going to bring you into the
modern era and the best part is that you
don't even have to pay for any of this
we'll help you finance it our
construction companies will build it and
since these projects are gonna make you
so much money you can use the money that
generates the payoff the loan and look
we know this will work because that's
what happened to us China became the
fastest growing economy ever known as
the China Miracle because we built all
this infrastructure don't you want your
country to be the next Miracle of course
I do they say so sign on this dotted
line please it wasn't offered Latin
America could not refuse so Lana America
loaded up on Chinese loans that went to
pay Chinese construction companies to
build Chinese infrastructure since 2005
Chinese state-owned Banks dished out 117
loans throughout Latin America over a
hundred billion dollars and 2021 alone
Chinese state-owned companies including
China Railway construction China
Communications construction and China
National offshore oil funded 11.3
billion dollars worth of projects in
South American countries from 2018 to
2020 China invested 16 billion dollars
in overseas mining including investing
in South America's lithium triangle the
region consisting of parts of Argentina
Bolivia and Chile these countries
account for 56 percent of the world's
lithium resources and China has been
quietly buying it up quartering the
market for natural resources to make
batteries China also represents the
largest investor in Peru's mining sector
controlling seven of Peru's largest
mines a hundred percent of Peru's iron
production and 25 of their copper output
China also owns two of the five largest
copper mines in Peru they've infiltrated
everything while becoming the world's
largest loan shark in the process in 20
2017 China overtook the World Bank and
the international monetary fund to
cement its position as the world's
biggest creditor and now China is using
this foothold to slowly build up its
military presence in Latin America the
larger threat she believes is China
which is pumping hundreds of billions of
dollars into the region to build
desperately needed infrastructure like
dams ports and cell phone networks but
there's always strings attached those
strings mean China and the regimes they
prop up can now track the activity of
their populations what would that
information give them it allows them to
possibly use health care for example if
you didn't vote a certain way then you
don't get health care you don't get food
and in their most ambitious move yet
China is building 29 New Ports in 17
different countries absolutely alarming
I worry about dual use of all of the
projects that they are putting in place
most of these companies from China are
state-owned Enterprises controlled by
the government and so can easily be
converted or transitioned into a
military use if necessary a conversion
like that would mean that China suddenly
went from zero military bases in Latin
America to dozens
foreign
[Music]
actual Chinese military forces into
Latin America the US would never stand
for it it will set off so many alarms so
China has been building up his military
power over there much more subtly from
2009 to 2019 China transferred a total
of over 600 million dollars worth of
major military hardware to five South
American countries Argentina Bolivia
Ecuador Peru and Venezuela and thus not
all since 2015 China has trained more
Latin American Military Officers than
the United States and that difference
has grown every year since China is also
training Latin American soldiers and
policemen as part of their friendly boot
camps to bring their militaries closer
together think about that America is
usually the one sending in special
forces units to train foreign militaries
to get them on our side but now China
has overtaken the US in that regard in
Latin America and all those airports
ports and essential infrastructure
they've been building across South
America all of that could be switched to
become military outposts overnights what
they're actually doing is they're
they're leasing for long periods of time
Act access to the mineral and the
locations that they are building so they
go in build an airport build a road
build water build everything they take
Chinese employees in to give those
Chinese employees jobs they work they
create all this infrastructure and the
local country signs a lease that says
the Chinese government can use this for
their own purposes so now China just
built 10 military bases all around the
globe they just call them airports until
the time comes that China calls in the
favor on their lease and says hey we're
going to move military transports and
Military troops
[Music]
foreign
right now China is holding on to
everything that matters in Latin America
China controls the trade the debts and
the military supplies of countries as
little as a few hundred miles away from
the U.S border but China is not done
quite yet China's next goal with Latin
America is to get them to join brics
brics is the alliance between five major
Global economies Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa they've burned
themselves a sort of an anti-g7 and
they're actively working to promote
their own political and economic
interests while undermining the West one
of their major goals that we've covered
is that they're planning on creating
their own currency to Dethrone the
dollar but to do that they're gonna need
to get a lot more countries on board
bricks needs to expand so that's why
they recently made Brick's membership
open for application and almost
instantly 19 countries applied to join
the alliance most of the countries that
want to join brics are being kept a
secret they obviously don't want to get
on America's bad side on the off chance
they don't get in but we do know that
Argentina was one of the first countries
to apply which means there's a good
chance other Latin American countries
are in the mix too but bricks is far far
from the first time another Power tried
to circumvent the dollar it's just that
the previous times a country tried to do
this America usually invades them to
teach them a lesson and the most
absolutely insane story of this is Libya
under Muammar Gaddafi see Muammar
Gaddafi had turned Libya into somewhat
of a socialist Paradise there was free
education free healthcare free water
housing was made of Human Rights and
Gaddafi did all this without taking a
single Cent from the US or the West
Gaddafi gave the middle finger to the
Western colonizers he showed Africa that
it was possible to be successful without
the West that they could break free from
their colonizers Gaddafi was Africa's
Last Hope the work Gaddafi went too far
was when he announced plans for a new
gold-backed currency called the Golden
Gnar that Africa could use to cut out
the west and for America that was just a
bridge too far and it set the war
machine in motion Gaddafi was soon
painted as evil and was incited a Civil
War in Libya which set the stage for a
NATO invasion of Libya eight months
later and the West finally got what they
wanted Gaddafi was dead the golden Gnar
was dead along with Africa's last ounce
of Hope but because violent stories like
this get demonetized on YouTube We
expose it all in a new private
documentary that you can watch right now
by clicking the card on the screen this
is one of my favorite videos that we
made so far and you are gonna love it
and this YouTube membership is where we
post one of these documentaries every
month that is too controversial to be
posted publicly so that you can learn
all the stuff they won't teach you in
college for just five dollars a month
click the card on the screen to watch
now